the problem in our world is that hate is  very loud happiness is very content  when you're a happy warrior when people  [ __ ] on you you can just move on yeah  yeah i feel a sense of responsibility as  a happy warrior that when people come at  me i can put in work to give them more  love  i wonder what it means when you show  somebody love for the first time in the  face of them giving you hate does that  give them hope it has to it makes sense  to me and if i can give somebody hope  that the world isn't just cutthroat and  hates each other that i have the  emotional strength to deploy love in the  face of hate  and that gives them the debate that  maybe there's others out there like that  as well that's what we should be doing  for each other i agree